uh what did you make of it Mr Stevenson
good morning
well I think the Prime Minister finished
the conference on a high we've got to
acknowledge there's been a bit of a
difficult few days for her but I think
she finished in a high and most
importantly of all she was setting out a
very strong policy agenda one which I
think all conservative MPS will
certainly get behind and I think it's an
extremely important agenda for people
such as myself who live in the north of
England where we've obviously been
advocating the leveling up agenda for
some time it's a Manifesto commitment
from 2019 and I feel very confident that
she's committed to it
did you vote for her
uh no I didn't but I don't think that's
relevant now what we've got to do is get
behind our prime minister we had uh an
election uh We've chosen our prime
minister uh she is now leading the party
and I think she's setting out a very
clear agenda one that clearly divides us
from opposition parties because you've
got people like the greens who don't
want to see growth in the economy
liberal Democrats never sure what
they're up to and labor who are devoid
of ideas we now have a clear agenda and
from the northern perspective we've long
said what is leveling up about it's two
things it's about improving people's
lives and it's about closing the gap
between those less prosperous areas with
the more prosperous areas and that means
growing our economy so I want to see the
policies that will lead to Greater
growth in the north of England we can
close that Gap
and does that include slashing the 45p
rate of tax and also Bankers bonuses
caps being removed
I think at the end of the day they were
a distraction to what we want to
actually achieve and I'm actually very
pleased the government to put that to
one side we can then concentrate on the
agenda and the policies that will
actually deliver the growth in the
places I want to see it so you're
cutting National Insurance I think is a
positive but it's not just about tax
cuts it's also about looking at the
amount of Regulation that there is and
it's looking at public sector investment
and skills in infrastructure and
attracting the private sector which
ultimately is the gold private sector
will lead to greater wealth creation
greater wealth creation leads to better
Public Services which is what something
which we all want to see okay so you you
also think it's a good idea to remove
the cap on Bankers bonuses then
well that's a private sector matter and
to be perfectly honest if we gain more
tax from that we can then use that tax
to pay for public services but what is
most important is about growing the
economy in different parts of the
country I want to see the economy of
this north of England close the gap with
some more successful Parts I want to see
other parts of the country continue to
be successful but we do need to see the
north grow as well okay if it's a
private sector matter why was it brought
up in the mini budget
well I think what's more important is
about looking at the policies that we're
going to take us forward that will grow
the economy in the north of England and
I think I think I know that's not my
question Mr Stevenson my question is
about Bankers bonuses you say it's a
private sector Master quite clearly
isn't because it was the government that
put the cap on there and I'm asking you
what impact that has on leveling up and
what your constituencies constituents
think about it
well I think it'll have a limited impact
on leveling up because I think leveling
up is about seeing the investment in the
north of England and other parts of the
country because we obviously want to see
the whole country uh level up and I
think it's the policies that will drive
that that are far more important it's
about increasing infrastructure
improvements it's about seeing skills
Improvement and it's about seeing uh
private sector being attracted to those
areas so that they can grow those vocal
economies see productivity increases
because it's through productivity
increase that you see how Society
increases wealth
so I'm sorry just to clarify are you
saying that you don't mind that cap
being lifted
I don't think it will have any great
impact on what we are trying to achieve
which is about growing the economy my
question Mr Stevenson just answer my
question if you would please do you
agree with uh Bankers bonuses cap being
lifted or not
I do not personally have a problem with
that
okay do you think that the people that
are your constituents that are
struggling to make ends meet will feel
the same way
I think people who I represent want to
see the local economy grow they want to
see investment into our area they want
to see their own individual lives
improve and that is what the gender that
the government is pursuing is all about
I want to see the Carlisle economy and
indeed the national economy improve I
want to see the standard of living with
the people in my area improve I want to
see the opportunities they have improve
and that is about investment and you are
starting to see that in places like
Carlisle we have investment going into
our University we have investment going
into our road infrastructure those are
the things that will improve the
productivity of the local economy and
therefore improve the lives the people
who live in my constituency okay the
good people of Carlisle won't carry
George that Bankers can get even bigger
bonuses than they did before
they all have different opinions on that
subject but I think far more importantly
people will be looking to what matters
in their own individual lives their own
communities and ultimately they want to
see the whole country succeed but I want
to concentrate on the policies that will
lead to an improved economy in Carlisle
and in other parts of the country yeah
the reason I'm asking you is of course
because Carlisle was a red wall State
until 2010 and it's exactly seats like
that that will have an opinion on uh
Bankers bonuses in the cap being lifted
and when they get into the polling booth
in 2022 December 2022 that could swing
it for them this government looking as
though they're looking after the fat
cats rather than leveling up in Carlisle
I disagree with that because I think
you're actually seeing direct investment
from government into places like
Carlisle I've already highlighted we've
got a Ring Road potential investment
we've got the university expanding in
the area we've seen job creation in the
area and I think what will matter to the
people of Carlisle at the next election
is has Carlisle improved has their own
individual lives improved and has the
opportunities for their own children and
families improved because that's a
critical thing I want to see everybody
improve their lives have greater
opportunity better jobs higher wages
greater productivity in the economy and
also our environment where they live and
their communities are prosperous that is
the policy of the present government
pursuing a growth agenda I think is the
right approach
uh that also I'm guessing I'd be
thinking about whether they can keep a
roof over their heads or even if they
can because mortgages have gone up so
high uh keep the heating on uh because
of increases uh in inflation the cost of
living and indeed mortgage rates because
this government was in danger of
crushing the economy
I don't think anybody disagrees that
there's good to be a difficult few
months I'm quite optimistic about things
I think inflation will drop
substantially next year interest rates
are rising not unique to the United
Kingdom interest rates are rising right
across the Europe and other parts of the
world I think they will ultimately
stabilize uh hopefully as the economy
recovers next year and you see inflation
drop that
interest rates will start to drop and
George we've also got to remember the
government has stepped in to support
families and businesses up and down the
country with the energy support that
they are giving Which is very very
substantial what I'd like to see
obviously is Energy prices generally
drop inflation drop in the car economy
start to grow as strongly and I think we
will see that next year yeah we all want
that to happen how high do you think
inflation is going to go before that
I'm not somebody who can predict these
things uh but I he just did predict that
it was going to go down I did yes but
not a specific figure uh what I did say
I think they will go down next year and
I think that will improve their people's
prospects okay it's good to talk to you
thanks very much indeed for joining us